so i just go back to release the damn
videotapes tell me what did pelosi know
when did she know it um let's find out
who you know who are these guys like
epps there's several of them who broke
the windows that's where you need to
start but like going after people who
were just out there pissed off about the
election i mean you know let's not
forget we're still you still have people
who have not accepted the election from
2016 because they believe that trump and
putin and russia all stole this why
because these liars like pelosi and
others told the american people that the
media went along with it and they
brainwashed people all over this country
so anyway that's all i have for january
6. i yearn i yearn for those good old
days those good old days of 2017 when
hillary was allowed to tweet that donald
trump is an illegitimate president and
it would not get taken down from twitter
when stacy abrams would say she won the
gubernatorial race in georgia and it
would not get taken down you used to be
able to question these things
i'm dave rubin and joining me today is a
former u.s congressman from california's
22nd district and now the ceo of truth
social devin nunes welcome to the reuben
report wow dave it's my honor great to
great to be with you i am glad to have
you on we met for about 10 seconds in
passing at mar-a-lago a couple weeks ago
during the 2000 mule's
debut and you're sort of right in the
thick
of uh the political
and the social media firestorm so let's
start actually well you know what let's
start somewhere else because of that
background that you got behind you i
sense you're in florida but you're a
former cali guy what's going on here
yeah you know we looked around much like
you in terms of where to locate the put
the headquarters
and you know it quickly got narrowed
down to florida and texas tennessee
and then you know this was a this was a
good spot relatively close to mar-a-lago
just on the other side of the state easy
to get to
um and then of course it's a it's a free
state it's a fun place to be we have a
lot of people who wanted wanted to be
here in terms of our tech folks so it
just it kind of made um
kind of made you know kind of perfect
sense to to be here
you know which is odd because you would
think a startup tech company for the
last 40 years would have been in silicon
valley in california but you know that
wasn't even on our list it wasn't it
didn't even make the list of even a
potential place was there literally not
even a moment where you guys were like
oh just in terms of the manpower or to
get the right programmers or whatever
else that you were like oh we have to do
this in silicon valley or the ship had
already fully sailed yeah not not didn't
even it didn't even it didn't even pop
up i mean look
you know for one you know i know my
background for the last five years and
you're doing a lot of the you know
involved with the the russia hoax and
the impeachment hoaxes and all of that
you know it's it's not even you know
sadly um you know if you're gonna if
you're more center right
there's a lot of places in this country
that are not safe to be and i can tell
you the bay area is is one of those
so as a cali guy and someone that
represented california's 22nd district
as i said is this sort of bittersweet
for you that you have to relocate and
and do truth down in florida the free
state of florida i mean i you know i
left california about six months ago i
have not looked back oh by the way i
don't know if you know this but every
time i gratuitously mention california
on the show i put money into this jar
yeah you have to yeah i don't know who
gets the money though well originally it
was i was going to help transport
someone from california a sane person
from california to florida but we've
decided i'm actually going to export a
democrat from florida and send them to
california i think oh that's okay that's
a good idea i was going to tell you
there's plenty of homeless people that
you can pick up and move from california
to here exactly um but but was that
bittersweet for you in a way
yeah i mean look i'm my family's still
out in california um you know my
family's been there in some cases for
almost 100 years like my family came
from the azore islands in in portugal uh
you know ag family and you know pretty
much everybody is is right around that
area i was born there and i represented
there
um and i don't take pride in it i mean i
love the state
but it's it's just untenable to operate
a business there i mean especially one
that's owned by president trump right i
mean it wouldn't even be possible
so you know where i am in the middle of
the state we like you know we like to
say that we're kind of that last uh
place that's left that's in a little bit
of sanity because we're
we're i know all the people in la and
san francisco call it drive
drive-through country but it also
happens to be the the bread basket of
the solar system right i mean everything
grows there i mean from almonds to
grapes to to raisins to you know every
damn thing you can eat they all grow
there and it's a beautiful place but you
know as you know you know we can't even
get i fought my whole career to try to
get water into the into the region um
and because the you know kind of the
green
uh global warming gods that they that
they pay homage to there in california i
mean we're actually cutting the damn
state off of water so you know look
at some point
you know i'm doing this job to open the
internet back up and and give the
american people their their voice back
and i'm proud to do it and we can
probably get into a lot about how i kind
of stumbled into this but but look i i i
it bothers me uh what's going on in
california and and look i want to see it
fixed but for the time being i just
don't know how you do it
you know without and it's one of the
reasons why i went to you know i i think
the way you do it is you have to win the
hearts and minds and right now people
are just getting so dumbed down they're
getting so destroyed
uh it's just uh
it's just tough because they're cut off
of information flow okay so obviously
we'll spend most of what we're talking
about here on the tech side and how we
can save free speech and all those
things but as long as we're talking
about california and i always put money
in the jar let's continue a little bit
uh gavin newsom just won the primary
he's obviously going to win re-election
is there anything to point to that is
hopeful in california or do you think
that it just needs to hit that rock
bottom whatever it might be if it's not
there already before things turn around
well i keep thinking it's going to get
hit rock bottom and i've been thinking
that for the better part of a decade but
i think what's happening instead is that
we're losing so many people like
yourself so people are essentially
voting with their feet they're leaving
so it's making it harder and harder so
you know we've got major you want to
talk about 2000 mules i mean 2 000 mules
is legal in california and so you know
how they've really destroyed it is they
essentially
now it's it's mandatory mandatory voting
mandatory registration so if you go to
the dmv for anything you get registered
to vote and in fact i think it's i think
it's totally chaotic we don't know who
the hell's registered there some people
get multiple ballots and they made legal
what was done in the last election in
other states which is thank god right
now still illegal but they made it legal
to essentially go harvest ballots in
california so i think a combination of
of basically uh
the whole state awash in ballots
uh the democratic party awash with money
so that they can afford to pay as many
people as they need to go pick up
ballots
um it's made it very hard you can only
kind of go to those places that are
almost like the alamo you have to
actually have money if you get targeted
like i have been you know several times
for the last few election cycles you
know we had to actually you know go
raise money from all over the nation so
we could fight back
and i think that's going to be the you
know the one place you say is there any
hope
um look we're there's 52 congressional
districts there
um they gerrymandered the hell out of it
with this commission this this last time
but i actually think that uh it is
possible that uh that we could pick up
two or three or four congressional seats
in california and look that has not been
possible for the last 10 years so that's
probably the only bright side right now
i mean obviously you had the the crazy
d.a that got beat in san francisco there
may be a recall from the one and one in
los angeles
but um but look i'll
i'll just tell you i was i was in
sarasota for a couple weeks
and uh kind of the first time that we
got the headquarters going
and then went back to california had not
been back for a couple weeks and
and i was greeted uh at the
little donut shop that i go to get a cup
of coffee by by a homeless guy like
standing in front there like with his
bike like essentially not letting you
until you give him money
i mean that's and you know the owner of
the business can't do anything i mean
it's just you know this because you just
left there but i i just don't know i
think people get a little bit of it's
almost like stockholm syndrome
and and people have just become
accustomed to it what started probably i
remember five or six years ago there was
a a church in my home city you know
tulare visalia area 65 000 people in
tulare
and
the you know there was a church that
said oh well you know we're a church we
you know we're gonna we're gonna help
people good thing you know they want to
help people well there was a couple
homeless people living there well pretty
soon the it went from 2 to 10 to 24 to
when the church said whoa whoa we can't
have this in our church parking lot well
now there's just homeless scattered out
through the whole city i mean there's
hundreds and hundreds just in just in my
home city right and that doesn't include
the district that i represented there
was homeless everywhere there and of
course you know what it is in in la but
i think that's just
you know
spending all this time in california
and washington dc uh the last decade or
so when you come to a state like florida
you realize like whoa wait a second i
just had a flashback to what it was like
to grow up in california in the 80s and
90s i mean that's what it feels like
here it's safe it's clean
um and it's totally different so i think
it it's gonna have to hit rock bottom i
think more people are gonna have to
have to leave until people pull their
heads out of their ass and and actually
start to start to vote right
and part of that is the free flow of
information which is which is why i left
congress to to start true social with
former president trump i know this is
not going to surprise you at all but i
have three employees in this room with
me right now who all moved with me from
california to the free state of florida
one of them got a california ballot to
vote in this past election to his new
address in florida i mean that tells you
everything you need to know about what's
going on over there
yeah and i've heard that time and time
again i don't even know
i mean this is how sophisticated they
are they learn people people move out
and they're still sending them ballots
right i mean
and and i guarantee you if you know i'm
sure if you're a democrat you moved out
or or or independent i guarantee you you
get the ballot i'm not so sure if you're
a republican you get the ballot yeah he
is a republican so he got it okay wow
that's good
they're the tech their tech guy must
have been taking he probably was a
didn't show up to work because of covet
or something yeah exactly made a mistake
didn't take him off the roll all right
so before we dive into the tech stuff
and sort of what shifted you in your
career and all that you know i have
spent literally
zero cumulative minutes talking about
january 6 on my program to me it is a
complete distraction it is it is
impeachment number three it is going to
end with nothing going anywhere it's
going to make a set of sort of very
confused people about the principles of
america even more confused uh but
because you've been in this with trump
for a while because you've been trying
to fight this information because you
were involved you know around the the
impeachment trial and all those things
is there anything you'd like to just say
about it broadly or specifically uh
because i just feel that i have no need
to entertain this that's really just how
i feel about it
yeah well i think you're you're you're
right to not entertain it i think kind
of my my quick thoughts are this the
institution
uh
in congress uh and all the institutions
in washington
um are collapsing all right so kind of
what we just talked about with
california it's happening
in our nation's capital also and what
what i say is we've just entered a a
dark chapter
of american history right now that
started in that 2015
16 time frame with the first that first
piece being
that
that people within the fbi and doj
thought it was perfectly okay to get
involved in politics and frame
a presidential candidate and ultimately
the entire republican party so it
started with oh it's a dirty trick get
the fbi to participate in it get get
informants to participate
walk all this stuff into the fbi and the
doj in different locations like what
came out in the in the recent sussman
trial
fully engaged the fake news media with
it
you know but but at the time they just
justified it in their own mind of well
it's just uh it's just donald trump so
you know no nobody cares about that
let's just you know write crap about him
and crap about him and crap about him
and first it started as well let's just
call him uh that he has ties to russian
oligarchs and then suddenly they move
that because there were no ties to
russian oligarchs and say well what the
hell let's just say he has ties to putin
because they knew that hillary clinton's
emails they were afraid that by the way
they never actually came out the emails
that the congress had an actual
investigation going on to because she
destroyed a server in a legal server you
know taking you back to that time frame
right yeah so
from there it just got worse right the
and i you know i was the one who
essentially came out like essentially on
day one or you know probably day you
know second or third week
and i said
russia stuff what the hell are you guys
talking about like i was just like six
months prior to this
you obama and your whole crew wouldn't
do a damn thing about putin as he
invaded crimea he was involved in libya
he was involved in syria and we won't
get into foreign policy discussion here
here today but
i knew it was
you know pure utter i think i can say
[ __ ] on your show you can say it so
i knew it was total [ __ ] because
you know i knew because as the chairman
of the in-house intelligence committee i
knew what they weren't doing
so you can't come you know come out
right after the election we were told
hey nothing unusual yeah putin's a thug
he's a bad guy he he messes around i
mean it's not unusual for him to mess
around in elections but you know all
they really found at the end of the day
that putin did was you know he bought a
few facebook ads which by the way
weren't even in the states that that
mattered right so that was the extent of
of
actual hard evidence that we had on the
intelligence committee we didn't have
anything else and that was the position
of the officials in the fbi uh and and
the other intelligence agencies that we
worked with until they decided to turn
on the operation so they did they ran a
dirty trick all through the campaign
and then they just doubled down with the
full power of the fbi and doj and you
know the rest and i had to take the you
know the brunt of that we exposed it all
um then it led to mueller uh the mueller
investigation total corruption right
they couldn't find you know they they
couldn't find anything on russia but
they found plenty of process
crimes that they went after people on
we had you know i had to sit out there
every single day you know how hard it is
when you've got 95 percent of the media
that is listening to democrats in
congress and people within within the
former intel people current intel people
mil you know retired four-star generals
you know who would constantly come out
and say well i can't tell you what i
know but it's really bad
right and i had to sit there and say
no you guys are lying right and you're
totally full of it so you know i had to
sit there and withstand that so that
molar hoax and then it goes into
impeachment you know the whole ukraine
impeachment was a whole other debacle
and then it and then look there was a
riot that that occurred at the capitol
and so you know what what do we need to
talk about there it's the same thing
that i said after day one you know day
one which was look there was intel that
that that we knew about that's now
you're starting to see some of that come
out pelosi knew about it the democrats
knew about it that's why the the trump
administration
uh was willing to have national guard
ready for the capital that's not unusual
it happens when you have big protests
especially or when you're getting ready
to to have an inauguration
it was the first time that i'd never
seen i mean they put up the fences for
anything right i was there for two
decades i mean oh my god there's gonna
be a protest the supreme court boom they
do like a double fence if anybody's if
you've been to washington dc the supreme
court's essentially right across from
the capitol they'll put like double
fences up get plenty of security that's
just for a supreme court protest that
you know some you know with for a few
hundred people
so the fact that they had the
intelligence they had approval for the
national guard there was no fencing put
up and now the way that they're going
about all this when you got this guy
uh you know so it really appears like
russia hoax 3.0 it's just like a another
version of it
you've got this guy ray epps who clearly
was inciting people
the guy is not even being arrested
he's not even being interviewed i mean
nobody seems to know anything about him
the dudes that living out in arizona i
mean you know just that's just one
example of what appears like there was
some type of federal involvement
in in in instigating ins you know
instigating the riot so
and when i say the riot
it should not be hard there's some 14
000 hours of videotape that i have
called for for the last you know when i
was in congress and now now and and even
today like release it they won't even
show the republicans the videotape right
so they're selectively showing showing
tape and there's cameras all over the
capitol dave that just so you know i
mean it's there's plenty of video
because of of however you know we never
even got the exact number of how many
people went into the capitol but what
i've said from from from day one is
release the videotape and the people
that i want
busted and prosecuted
are the ones who were fully masked up
they somehow had exactly the location to
go to and they had exactly the tools
they needed to break windows
and to this day i'm not sure i could be
wrong i mean it changes every day but
i'm not sure they have located those
what appear to be
maybe two to three dozen people at
different doors that broke those windows
i mean those people should be prosecuted
the full extent of the law we still
don't even know who the hell they are i
sense though what you're saying subtly
is that they might be feds right
i don't know who the hell they are we
don't know i mean i i mean i know that
eps guy i mean that's clearly fishy
right i mean he's living out in arizona
somewhere and i mean hell the night
before he's on videotape with with
people you know
trump supporters that were out there for
the rally which by the way
the idea that trump president trump or
anyone else would hold a rally on our
nation's mall in washington dc
that's only out of the norm when trump
does it
right i mean there are rallies there i
was just there i mean this past weekend
they had the pride rally and they had
some gun rally i think last time i was
in i was in washington dc they had a
uh they had like a police officer's uh
uh for fallen police officers rally so
the idea that it's like unusual somehow
that the the people can have rallies um
i mean that's at the cornerstone of our
of our democratic republic here right
and if you go back just you know four or
five six months before you had blm
riots who destroyed the capital shut it
down i my damn near got attacked you
know coming out of the when trump gave
his nomination speech in washington dc
just months before
so
you know the idea that suddenly now oh
you you can't have a rally it's it's
that's nonsense okay so i just go back
to what crimes were broken well clearly
the people who broke the windows the
rest of the people i mean a lot of
people had no clue that they couldn't go
into the capitol because look
the capital is normally open for the
public except when like during covet
when pelosi has you know closed it down
so so i just go back to release the damn
videotapes tell me what did pelosi know
when did she know it um let's find out
who you know who are these guys like
epps there's several of them who broke
the windows that's where you need to
start but like going after people who
were just out there pissed off about the
election i mean you know let's not
forget we're still you still have people
who have not accepted the election from
2016 because they believe that trump and
putin and russia all stole this why
because these liars
like pelosi and others told the american
people that the media went along with it
and they brainwashed people all over
this country so anyway that's all i have
for january 6. i yearn i yearn for those
good old days those good old days of
2017 when hillary was allowed to tweet
that donald trump is an illegitimate
president and it would not get taken
down from twitter when stacey abrams
would say she won the gubernatorial race
in georgia and it would not get taken
down you used to be able to question
these things but that's actually a
perfect segue to what i really want to
talk to you about which is big tech
censorship so you are running true
social
it's obviously president trump's
platform
i think some people know that the
infrastructure is run by the rumble
cloud for total transparency i am part
owner of rumble because of the deal that
we did with locals and i think we're
we're building some awesome stuff so at
some level we are kind of in business
together although this is the first time
that we've ever spoke except for that
that quick hello we had a couple weeks
ago um so what was was it a very natural
transition for you to say okay here i am
in the swamp it's corrupt as hell
everyone's lying about everything uh
maybe i can help clean things up on the
private side which would be the the
social media side
yeah it's a pretty interesting story
actually so
so i wrote this little pamphlet book
called countdown to socialism in july of
2020. so remember this is before the
censoring of the hunter biden laptop and
of course every all these people
millions of americans getting booted off
or censored on on the tech tyrant
platforms
well i had actually already quit twitter
because i realized that i was being
shadow banned and it was totally useless
for me to even be on the on the platform
so i was the first uh member of congress
to go to parlor okay so parlor was the
company that ultimately got bezos you
know cut off their their servers and
killed essentially killed the company
but i quickly realized that that i that
i had at parlor i mean finally so think
about i was on twitter from essentially
the very beginning i had a million
followers or something maybe a little
over a million followers well
when
when parlor got shut down dave i had
4.2 million followers on parlor
okay and partly i mean that was like in
a year in one year's time so
so
you know i i knew the censorship that
was going on okay i had also been capped
on instagram i've been like at 100 000
people i liked instagram actually i like
to use it i think it's interesting
people all over the globe are are on it
and we'll get more to instagram later
because i think it's important in terms
of the business aspect of of what we
have to do
but
insta but
instagram i've been capped at like 100
000 followers for like three years now
right i mean i don't grow and i used to
use it so
so anyway
um
2020 i write this pamphlet warn
everybody about that this is happening
at the same time i i noticed when oh dan
bongino who who you know um who was who
was also there that night so i had my
little podcast that i was doing
essentially and the reason i created
podcast different than you it wasn't to
it wasn't to make money or anything it
was actually i had to get away
find a way that that my constituents and
people all over the country could hear
directly from me without being censored
so i use my national email list and
database and all of everything that i
had through my campaign side and i was
able to network created this little
podcast
and bongino calls me he's like man
you're really doing well in this podcast
it's crazy cause like i even getting
like that i probably never beat you but
like i would be in the top 20 sometimes
you know when i first started it
and uh
and anyway
uh he tells me
hey man you got to go to youtube
i'm like oh okay [ __ ] i didn't know
anything about you know youtube so i
heard i knew about it i had like a
little account there but i never really
thought about doing video
so i did uh so we started doing uh doing
a simulcast right so i'd put it on the
audio side
and then i'd also put it up on on
youtube and what happened was incredible
my my audio just kept going up up up up
my video like shot up immediately
and then like if if it could have had
negative views it would have had
negative views like it it flatlined okay
and i said this is impossible this this
can't be possible so
i told my team i said let's just find
let's find a freaking video player
because clearly people there's no way
i'm sending this out to a million people
and people aren't at least like i have
enough family members that would at
least feel sorry for me and at least
click on it to give me a view you know
and of course it didn't make sense
either because the audio listens we're
going up right it's in the heart of the
election time i mean it's all about
russia hoax ukraine hoax impeachment
hoaxes i mean all that stuff is hot
people want to hear about it um
and i was you know i had really good
guests on on on the show and so i just
said and we've we came across this
rumble player
and it's a it's a great story because so
i had 9 000 followers on youtube i
thought
must be okay i don't know how many
people are on youtube it sounds okay to
me um didn't know any better so i call
up rumble and chris
first chris from rumbled owner the ceo
of rumble he said he at first he thought
he was under investigation from by the
congress
and then he quickly went into because i
just asked him this question i was like
look man i just want you i just want a
place i can park my video and if i put
in
devin nunes podcast right that's that
was the name of it not very creative but
that was it
and i said will it come up and chris was
like well yeah of course like why are
you that seems kind of dumb i said well
go try it right now on youtube
and that was like a moment for for chris
it was like oh my god you couldn't find
it like he couldn't find the podcast
like he didn't believe it existed and
then i had to send him the link so he
could eventually find that yeah there
was a channel there was a link
so
um long story short
i get up on
on rumble and so like i said 9 000
followers on youtube
in three weeks so so no one knows of
rumble in the united states of america
no one this is like pre bondino pre
anybody who went to rumble
i had 35 000 followers in three weeks
and in three months i had almost 400 000
and now you know i'm sitting here today
at a million and i don't really you know
now i'm just kind of posting news clips
on it but
but that shows you right there i mean
those are real numbers right i gave you
the parlor numbers i gave you the rumble
number numbers
so
and in the book that i wrote i
essentially warned the you know people
about that there was a funnel effect
that was taking place it wasn't so much
that 95 of the news media is is fake and
slanted
because because i can handle the 95 5
because i think we have a lot of good
places you know between the podcasters
like yourself and and all the different
news companies the investigative
reporters that we have you know we we
can hold our own 95 to 5.
but we can't but the difference between
between what you know what you know 10
years ago and today and i and i learned
this through the russia hoax and how
people's perceptions were and what
people were learning
is i i realized that we were just 60 of
of america was just kind of tuned out
you know never even knew anything about
the russia hoax and what i call it is
the funnel effect so it's when you take
that
95
you feed it through a funnel which you
know ultimately becomes these phones
right here right that are going through
you know youtube facebook instagram tick
talk etc
and then the left is deciding
what people are able to see especially
those people that are most important
like conservatives you know people that
always vote i mean they're going to know
the difference but it's those people who
really only they only vote in general
elections they don't pay attention a
whole hell of a lot um but you know
they'd want to do their civic duty and i
mean we sat there for you know year
after year pounding away it was clear
the only people that had anything to do
with putin in russia or hillary clinton
and the democrats and adam schiff and
democrats on the committee i mean it was
plain day direct evidence that this
wasn't complicated right
but yet nobody knew it and you still you
still had even by election 2020 you
still had over half of americans thought
that the republicans
had and trump had something to do with
russia so i there was just
it was just a big problem and i knew
that until that funnel that funnel that
the the left controls which is why
they're so ticked off about elon musk
buying twitter until you until you get
rid of that funnel we're going to
continue to have this problem like the
problems we discussed in california and
the problems we see in washington dc
that's kind of
the short story of it all it's so
interesting because
the the problems that you were trying to
solve for yourself are exactly what led
you to this new career and that's
exactly why i started locals i was
having the same exact problems as you as
you'll love this one i remember this is
a couple of years ago now when i was
about to hit a million subscribers on
youtube and at the time you may remember
you could go on socialblade where they
did a live track of subscribers so you
could literally just watch a graph and
the numbers would grow and i would every
time i got within about twenty thousand
of a million i would lose fifty thousand
and then it would slowly grow again and
then i'd lose forty thousand and it took
me months when i when it should have
been way before and then what did
socialblade do well youtube deactivated
their api so they could no longer track
in real time because it was becoming too
obvious so one of the things that i say
all the time about social media it's not
the stuff that we know that they're
doing i'm worried about it's the stuff
that we do not know that i'm most
worried about so okay so all of that
added up
uh how is truth going to solve some of
the problems we could go into all of the
shadow banning you don't see subscriber
videos uh you know the bands the
censorship okay fine we can do all that
my audience gets it how is truth going
to solve some of this stuff yeah so so
look i mean one of the one of the things
that we're doing is we're riding on top
of we call it riding on rumble the
rumble rails right so the same thing
that locals is using you know rumble is
getting into that marketplace it's
critically important because you know we
have to have data centers that these big
giant tech companies can't can't kill
and cut off right
so that's why you know we've partnered
we've partnered with rumble and then
what we're doing like the product we're
trying to that we're that we're building
out right now
uh is is one that that we envision
is taking kind of the best of all these
social media companies that are out
there
in terms of you know twitter is kind of
just a simple message board
then you have a lot better technology at
instagram facebook and and tick tock so
we're trying to take the best of best of
all of that and put it into into one
platform and people who have who i've
seen you know who have seen true social
uh you know which were only you know
just a few months old right now and
we're right now we just have a simple
chronological feed uh no we don't use
any algorithms but you will see already
that we are trying to
do a really good job with video and
no surprise we're using rumble for our
video infrastructure so we're trying to
tie
all of this together so that we have a
product that takes the best of all these
social media companies because
then i said that we would come back to
this
and here we are
the
you know the eyeballs in this country
are are on instagram
and at tick tock right you essentially
have kind of an older demographic
that are on facebook that are probably
over the age of 50
from 50 down to 25 instagram just
dominates the market and then under 25
is which which is really scary this is
scary as hell uh chinese owned tick tock
and all these young people on tick tock
so
for us to
and for us to compete with with twitter
like like that's you know look you know
we're not going to ban people that's
kind of an easy market for us like
people that want to be on twitter get
news that sort of thing because your
twitter sucks so bad and a lot of a lot
of our people are never going to go back
go back to twitter so that's an that's
kind of an easy market but to really
grow this company we've got to get into
the mainstream of of people that are
don't want to just do politics and news
all the time but want to communicate and
actually
social network
uh you know knowing that we're not going
to shove some algorithm in their face i
think that's our comparative advantage
is we're going to do
every we're going to do a lot of things
really well
but you're not going to be canceled
we're not going to steal your data we're
not going to shove some algorithm into
your phone on the stuff that we think
you need to see
and that's our comparative advantage and
it's really just about filling out the
feature set so
you know we're in the apple app store
we've been there for a couple months now
we just got truesocial.com now you can
anybody can sign up from any device
um including you can sign up on android
but you just have to kind of bookmark it
and go back um and then we're hopeful to
get into the google play store here soon
so then it's simple for people that like
to like to have apps um and then it's
really about the features that we're
that we're going to be rolling out
so so the features
people love features there'll be more
features for sure but how worried about
are you about just some of the way the
internet works now so for example
truth is in the app store uh you know
twitter booted trump and then you know
there was this this concern that if elon
if he ends up getting twitter and he uh
puts trump back on if trump was to go
back on even though trump has said he
won't go back on it he's all in on truth
that the app store could then boot
twitter that there's that this is
multi-layered at many different levels
yeah so the only it's you you cut right
to it right the only
two platinum the reason that we
that we you know we went to apple first
um you know i've had a long um you know
my whole career i dealt with apple um
they're
they're
less woke than than others um they do
have republicans that work there i've
dealt with them for a long time
president trump felt like we could work
with them and that's why we chose chose
apple first because we had to you know
if you're not on the apple app store and
you're not on the google play store it's
just tough to ultimately compete against
instagram and tick tock right
so now the good thing is is that
is that we're trying to be a family
friendly
place to be right so we're not we're not
looking to have any illegal activity
we're not you know we don't want like
porn on there and
and and you know some vulgarity is okay
but you can't get crazy about it so so
we really want to be family friendly and
that right now is you know so far
um we've had a great working
relationship with apple
um google we waited
uh you know kind of for that to be last
i mean we're because now we're up on the
web you know truesocial.com anybody can
get onto it even if apple was to was to
get rid of us you could still have your
account
um and google's just more problematic we
already talked about some of those
issues but we're working with them
um you know i i
i can't as a at this time i can't say
anything that they're trying to keep us
off the google play store um but look
once again and we have a little bit of
an advantage that you know we're not
looking for violence and illegal
activity on the platform we really want
to we really want to keep that to a you
know a minimum
um i think that's going to make it
really tough for them to kick us off
their stores plus they already know look
they're not stupid here dave
republicans are likely going to smash
the left in the elections
you see big tech running ads constantly
all over the place saying how great they
are so i think they are a little bit
worried about what republicans could
could ultimately do so look if we i
think here at truth social we're a
family friendly place where you know
we're just not going to censor people
for politics you can talk about any damn
thing you want on the platform you know
politically
um but we don't want a lot of the
garbage that i think they would try to
use to wedge to to get us kicked off
these platforms and that's you know to
to our advantage
so when uh when elon you know now it's
about two months ago first started
grumbling about maybe buying twitter how
were you feeling about it and how did
you feel when president trump uh well i
don't remember which order it was did
president trump first say he wasn't
going to do it and then sort of went
after elon a little bit or was it the
other way around and and what do you
make of him just getting in the mix yeah
i don't make much of of the i think you
know i mean i i i've only met elon musk
a couple times but he seems like he's
real obviously brilliant guy very very
sharp but kind of very funny guy right
it's why he that's why he has you know a
big following on social media because
he's he's he's a creative dude
um but if you if you remember and the
fake news has basically ignored this
surprise surprise but the mission of of
of our company you know true social is
very simple like we're here to open the
internet back up
and give people their voices back
right it's a very simple very simple
business plan and mission and so you
know i like to say that that president
trump didn't need a new business
and i sure as hell didn't need a new job
it's just that what the hell do you
expect us to do when you kick all these
people off of social media i mean
including the former president united
states who had no voice at all plus
millions of his followers had no voice
at all not to mention you know all the
censoring that we that we already
discussed so
so the fake news has ignored this but
when it came out originally that the
elon musk was looking at buying twitter
we're like hey go for it you know like
that's that's our mission like if we can
if you can bust up one of those big tech
companies great have at it
and so you know we've always been
supportive of it but at the same time
what i what i said from the very
beginning said look the place needs a
lot of work because there's a hell of a
lot of bots there and and we already
knew that i knew that from my experience
on on having parlor account a rumble
account
having a big twitter account and then
also just in our beta test period of
true social how is it possible
that people who had been on twitter
forever and instagram in in many cases
most people were getting more engagement
on our platform during beta testing than
they were getting on these big tech
platforms now you can say some of that
shadow banning some of that sensorine
but i think it's also that that twitter
and you notice i've spent a lot of time
talking about facebook instagram and
tick tock there's a reason
it's twitter is just a global pr wire
it's where when barack obama wants to
make a statement like he did last week
he hadn't been on he hadn't been on
twitter forever and i know he made some
statement i think about the shooting in
in texas i mean it's a place for
celebrities and political hacks and
reporters to go put put stuff out it's
not where people go to social network so
it's from our from my perspective you
know we're not you know we're all for
opening this thing back up it's it's a
global platform uh you know meaning
twitter i don't know if elon's gonna do
it but i think what he's realized now is
what we knew you know going back is that
it's full of of bots
and you know bot is a kind of a a big
term but it's basically it's a
combination of bots spam accounts fake
accounts you know corporate accounts
every corporation in the world has has
an account but the fact is they're just
not active and they don't engage
so
so that's kind of uh you know so we're
also you know we're very supportive of
it and i think what you saw just to kind
of finish up with that
is that i think elon made some funny
remark about president trump and
president trump went back and made a
funny remark about him and um and now
president trump's you know basically you
know it it's it's got to play like
people why wouldn't i get so many calls
even from like well i don't really talk
to fake news but from even people who
are not fake news and they'll say like
well if he runs for president again
isn't he gonna have to go back on on
twitter i'm like
no like why there's nobody there like
you can make a different argument about
some of these bigger platforms i don't
he would never go to tick tock before
because of the chai comms but
you know i mean look instagram and
facebook still have a lot of people
right so
what do you what do you think he would
do i mean i guess that's the question
i think the goal here is is that you
know from from our perspective
is to you know we've got some really we
just just just uh in the last 10 days or
so we rolled out some really important
features uh on our platform we've got
some additional features that will
hopefully roll out here in the next two
to three weeks
um and then i know i'd like to get our
platform to a point where
um
you know where it does really take the
best of all those platforms and then
look we're going to be in direct
competition to them and remember we're
only open right now you got to remember
we're only open in the united states
that's the only place we're open right
now
so imagine once we you know you know
think about when we when we open this up
globally
yeah how concerned are you that you know
maybe apple will be okay and and you
know google will let you in but just the
other the other trickery i mean i know
they can't pull a parlor on you
obviously because truth is using the
rumble infrastructure so it's it's in
essence it's truth's infrastructure but
just some of the other trickery and
shenanigans that they can do
well you know what we've we've really uh
built this thing from the ground up
piece by piece right and that's what i
kept saying you know when i took over
when i took over the company uh the fake
news didn't like this but i said you
know they said oh what are you gonna
launch and i said well it for sure won't
be you know it'll be you know after the
first quarter
and and of course they never reported on
this even though i said it 500 times and
i'll say it for the 500 first time is i
said look we're going to be we're not
anybody on anybody's timeline but our
own
like we're going to launch when we're
ready to launch right so we wanted to
that's why we had to you know we had to
make sure the rumble cloud was ready
when we switched over to the rumble
cloud that's when we essentially went
out of beta and opened up for anybody on
on apple now we're up you know now we
have our our web-based application so
anybody can get it from any device
but we're building this block by block
dave and we're doing it in such a way
that nobody's going to be able to shut
us down i think what you might be
alluding to that we do have to you know
be sensitive to
um are our ddos attacks right attacks to
try to take us down and you know i know
rumble's had some of that we've had
we've had some of that we know that's
going to be a uh you know problem you
know
into the future but look we're we have
we have a good team of people and
rumble's been around a while and and
they're very very helpful plus the team
that we've built here at true social i
think
you know outside of kind of those those
attacks
there's nobody
that's going to be able to shut us down
well i love the fact that you were in
government you saw a problem you're in
the private sector trying to solve that
problem and uh you know that this that
this idea that i had about four years
ago is now part of the solution to that
problem so i appreciate you taking the
time devin oh man it's yes it's it's
great i've been i've been flirting with
locals i've been on there kind of watch
it's it's an it's an interesting
platform i i
it really is a place for
you know for those
those independent content creators where
they're not going to have to be beholden
to
you know to kind of the big the big
monopolies or the big companies so it's
you know congratulations and i think we
build it for you whatever you do with it
is on you it's as simple as that it's
the same how's that yeah no i'm i i
think it's going to continue to grow and
i think it's going to be a great home
for creators and you know we're going to
look to where we can work with you guys
continue to work with with rumble and uh
and locals and i don't know you i don't
know if you know but some of uh some of
your uh uh engineers and tech people
have been very very helpful in terms of
we built as as we've been building out
our platform and we're very thankful for
for that support uh for you and your
team that have offered that awesome well
i sense you'll be in sarasota a lot more
often and since i'm here in miami i
guess we're going to have to meet what
would be right in the middle something
like uh doral or something like that
we'll find something yeah alligator
alley right
oh exactly we'll meet in the middle of
alligator alley they got the panthers
and the gators there uh devin nunes it's
been a pleasure thank you thanks a lot
dave if you're looking for more honest
and thoughtful conversations about
politics instead of non-stop yelling
check out our politics playlist and if
you want to watch full interviews on a
variety of topics watch our full episode
playlist all right over here and to get
notified of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell